pensez bien à trop de coups de pied se
met à chanter un chant tiennent deux
roues idiot janvier 2002 cela fait à
peine quelques jours que les français
ont des centimes d'euro dans leur
porte-monnaie et déjà ils râlent avec
mes lunettes noires de loin je vois pas
les piquets de grève de trop beaucoup
trop incertains mais voit bien tourner
un peu perdu avec les pis on va s'y
faire tu mets les formes hier face à
cette grogne
dès janvier les journalistes
s'interrogent les pièces de 1 et 2
centimes d'euro vont elles disparaître
de la circulation
si aucune décision dans ce sens n'a
encore été prise la question alimente de
plus en plus les conversations
trois semaines après leur apparition ces
pièces sont loin de faire l'unanimité
auprès des consommateurs trop petit
encombrante et peu pratique pour régler
ses achats les arguments sont nombreux
oui mais voilà deux clans s'opposent
ceux qui veulent voir disparaître ces
petites pièces et arrondir les prix et
ceux défendus par des associations de
consommateurs qui craignent que des
prises à randy n'entraîne une
augmentation déguisée et si les
consommateurs se plaignent de ces
centimes les professionnels ils seront
tous contents d'arrondir mais il faut
bien se dire qu'ils vont pas arrondir à
la baisse qui vous racontent dire au
dessus un pour faire des prix ronds donc
c'est l'intérêt des consommateurs
d'accepter ces petites pièces et de les
manipuler d'apprendre à les manipuler
les années passent et chacun reste campé
sur ses positions
jusqu'en 2013 où la question de la
survie de ces centimes se pose au plus
haut niveau
à la commission européenne avec un
nouvel argument le coût de production de
ces santons priverait les pièces de un
ou deux centimes coûte cher à la
fabrication elle coûte environ 3
centimes en moyenne dont elle coûte plus
cher que ce qu'elles valent et par
ailleurs les gens ne les utilise pas
vraiment ils les gardent de côté elles
sont trop encombrante
donc aujourd'hui on se pose la question
est ce que ces pièces sont utiles
des pays comme la belgique la finlande
les pays-bas ou l'irlande ont déjà
répondu à cette question en arrondissant
tous leurs prix afin de ne plus utiliser
les pièces de 1,2 centime
une décision étendue à toute l'union
européenne
avant de dire adieu au petit pièce la
commission planche sur une analyse
d'impact d'un arrondissement aux 5
centimes près de tous les tarifs en
europe
bref le débat pour ou contre est encore
en cours
[Musique]